[Music]
celebrations have begun in China marking
70 years since the Communist Party took
power large parades are being held in
Beijing they're aimed at reflecting the
country's increased wealth and military
strength our correspondent Rob Matheson
has more on what's going on in Beijing
these 70th anniversary celebrations were
an opportunity for China to be able to
show off its military strength we've
seen thousands of troops we've seen
hundreds of tanks and aircraft
this was definitely China saying to the
world we are a strong military force but
it was also an opportunity for President
Xi Jingping to send a cautionary note to
the people of China yes he said we
should celebrate the achievements that
China has made up to this point but also
we should be careful there is our rough
road ahead the analyst suggests that
what he's talking about is the state of
China's economy earlier on this year the
expansion rate of China's economy slowed
to 6.2 percent that's still a
significant rate but it's the first time
in 27 years that China's economy has
started to slow down and President Xi
Jingping knows that his government is
going to be judged by the Chinese people
on how he handles the economy the other
element of course was references to the
situation in Hong Kong the ongoing
protests there just across the border
some of which have been directed against
the Beijing government he reiterated
again the China was determined to
maintain the one country two systems
approach that he believed was going to
work in Hong Kong was also working in
the special administrative area of Macau
but also perhaps that was a diplomatic
message to Taiwan Taiwan is resisting
challenges from China to become part of
China China firmly believes that Taiwan
should be included in China but Taiwan
has been watching very closely the
protests have been going on in
Kong and have been resisting very
strongly any attempt by China to be able
to take it over
so perhaps President Xi using the
opportunity to send a message that China
will stand by the one country two
systems approach it will guarantee
greater economy for special
administrative regions and sending a
message perhaps to Taiwan that this
system can work